walk in to this video playing best man
from from the US my rating has with some
luck reach 2,300 again it's been a while
so really down deep down with the rating
okay a close term close dream something
that I at least have some experience in
is playing a slower set up with them
with d3 I know it's playing defy this is
this is kind of curious now it's
basically just tempo down on the on a
midline he has not played rookie one
though okay I I won't try to overthink
things here I'm just I'm just to move up
compared to the line that I normally
play but this is obviously not very
important this totally closed position
93 sm somewhat somewhat uncommon this is
set up after night to f7 which I'm going
to play shortly he does not really want
to take on g7 but with 93 it does look
like he has a retreat square
interesting I even have f 5m as an
activist I can also take it's not not
bad takes on the g four tix on age six
up going to I going to play it simple
not doing anything fancy it's simply a
slightly more comfortable version of
what I'm playing in the main line here
I'm ready for you get for example yeah
i'll be just exchanging on the FR I just
not really get it again give it up
now this is ok I I really welcome some
peace trades due to my disadvantage in
space aha no is retreating this piece
after this I guess he wants to trade
queens right ok check I don't mind that
okay if I go f5 now this is possible I
guess so let's play a five ok retreating
can I ring the deep on that's really
what what I alternately want to do win
this pawn on d5 putting pressure here so
that at the end I can get a d5 and the
f7 night should be should be activated
but I don't really see how hmm how can i
activate this night
mind if some
and I'm not sure and I spend a little
bit more time here than I actually
should okay
taking a night have six wins upon okay
let's do that oops it's not winning upon
didn't see that at all 94 94 the ship
takes e7 but this is really weak yet see
495 now I will win this ultimately night
c5 d7 be 65 on 95 d 3 now that's even
better with night f four and then taking
on d5
mp3 may be coming but I can go here yeah
takes just attacking here okay to see
for miles oh wait now if I a b6
obviously yeah I'm winning winning porn
snow on light to see forms also just
take this night on see for some
dominating the night on d to easiest
should beat you to get them and get the
King into the game King f88 d7 something
like that I'm morning now c4 is really
neat the swear check
check yeah this promotes the pawn
ultimately white resins young lady trade
it I think the problem is that right
after this straight Oscar Richard hard
to play and think on phone yeah maybe is
playing on the phone now that's that's
that's tricky I know I tried it see that
one that on my mobile very difficult to
do um ok anyway f5 yeah the problem is
f5 is an advanced that black wants to
make to undermine the d5 pawn and it's
very difficult sometimes to play this
advanced in the middle game with Queens
own but with Queens off I'm gladly
playing this and here that's it's
interesting very interesting moment I
have multiple ideas even F force not
totally crazy but I want to try to get
to the pawn and the problem is my nights
are not very well placed I was thinking
about 95 maybe this was a was a good
move but I wasn't totally sure about
this continuation he does not have any
tactic yeah like night f5 or something
known yeah I wasn't sure about this
ultimately I decided to take and then
get this night over to f6 and possibly
also see for Bishop da b6 these are the
ideas that black has trying to get the
d5 pawn at the end and Tim yeah this is
he really didn't do anything against it
maybe an assist must be good right I
thought I'm just winning a pawn
he went here oh I'm stupid I'm so stupid
sometimes I calculated correctly yeah
that Knight takes e4 might there and
local Delano maybe correctly that it
might ultimately win but I can Jeff
course just take and play age six and he
resigns I'm a piece up okay no this was
a bit easier so I went here and I
thought that this should win but the
computer gives night in one with
equality this is a bit bit shocking I
really thought I'm almost winning nice
one maybe I don't get to attack the porn
thats its maybe but as possible force I
thought this one I also got this idea
mmm interesting yeah you can go here and
he has this counter attack yeah this is
the point 91c to a 3m yeah this makes I
mean okay I should take I should win the
pieces stuff in any case better but this
makes it even more terrible what I did I
thought this would win but night 91 is a
very strong defense after this I really
don't 92 is still valid 9224 here no 94
instead of bees b3 lose cancer play this
who is also ignored not a very good game
I did here I overlooked many thanks now
why does better aim so winning this 65
Wow
dad was worried I was just am I should
just take that just win the pizza I
thought about this but just check yeah
so this is not not at all working and
90-84 I did stupid ok oh it wasn't
interesting game yellow dress thanks for
watching